a dream vacation who has what turns out
into a nightmare the line's very crazy
right now the flights are skyrocketing
and it's getting out of hand quite
frankly they cancel my flight as i'm
boarding the plane i don't know why the
airlines don't have enough personal or
staff or what the reason is
welcome back to cbs mornings those are
just a few of the thousands of travelers
who got a rough ride at airports over
this fourth of july weekend believe it
or not
there are ways to prepare for this kind
of chaos and that's why we bring in
somebody like brian kelly better known
as the points guy knows most of them
he joins us now with some tips to
survive travel trouble
all right good morning great to see you
happy fourth of july
i noticed you're not in an airport this
morning which may be the first signal um
but uh look one of the things we keep
hearing of course is there's been these
cancellations
and
questions about sort of what you can get
back if what kind of refund or
reimbursement rights do people have with
the airlines if this happens to them
yeah so your rights in the united states
are that you get a full cash refund if
your flight is delayed more than four
hours or canceled so do not let the
airline give you a voucher get the cash
however if you're traveling to europe
this summer they have a lot more
consumer protections uh so it's called
eu 261 compensation look it up if you're
flying to the eu
uh or home from the eu and that's coming
in handy this past weekend a lot of
european airlines had delay rates of
over 50 percent so know your rights but
unfortunately in the u.s we don't have
compensation that's owed to you but the
silver lining is if you used a credit
card uh that has travel delay or
interruption coverage your credit card
company may reimburse you for all those
extra costs like you know getting a room
at an airport hotel or getting a rental
car
when you say cash though are they
literally supposed to hand it over right
there or they just refund it back to
your account i mean you're telling me i
can go up to the counter and they're
going to run a refund right there for me
if this works the way well it's not
going to be right away it's it's not
going to be cash although if you are
bumped from a flight you know there's a
recent story about a delta airlines
customer getting 10 000
yeah uh in in cash you know or in uh in
you can get flight vouchers as well so
but generally no they don't have stacks
of cash at the gate agent area it'll
usually go back on to your original form
of payment
and listen this should not be coming as
a surprise to airlines though they're
calling it like revenge travel right
that we just had to get out we didn't
care how much it was going to cost
insurance is for wusses we need to go
but it started last year why are we
seeing
this chaos now when they've had you know
at least a year to know that we're ready
to get out
yeah and to add insult to injury the
airlines took billions of dollars in
taxpayer money to not lay off employees
but the airlines in many cases did early
retirements you know they got rid of
those really expensive senior employees
and they didn't think demand was going
to come back this quickly so they in my
opinion kind of got their hand caught in
the cookie jar but i will say this is
more than just airlines the government
we need to invest in our infrastructure
system air traffic control there are a
lot of different parts of our travel
infrastructure that are quite frankly
crumbling and it's not going to get
better anytime soon unfortunately
brian it's vlad so uh have you seen
those videos of baggage that's just
piled up in airport terminals thousands
and thousands and thousands of luggage
uh look at this look at these images
this is sort of unbelievable and both
you and marie pointed out about the
billions of dollars just remember where
that money came from taxpayers the
american people paid that money for
these airlines to bail them out so what
can travelers do about a situation like
this
so the biggest thing with checked bags
never ever ever put anything super
important medications always take that
in the cabin with you if you're checking
bags these days you've got to put i put
apple air tags in all of my checked
luggage and it'll tell me pretty much in
real time exactly where the bag is
because as you'll see in in those cases
where there's just at heathrow thousands
of bags if you have an air tag you can
look where your bag is if the airline
says no it's not at the airport you can
say actually yes it is here it is this
is what it looks like can you let me go
back and find my bag i also recommend
don't just have a normal black bag
because no one's going to find that for
you in one of those huge facilities i
travel with a salmon colored suitcase so
if my bag ever does go missing i can say
hey it's this bright salmon one which is
pretty easy to pick out when you uh look
in a facility like that
now brian everyone's heard your advice
and there's going to be like a ton of
people buying salmon colors i already
put it in my shopping cart on amazon
salmon collards did you hear about that
you so much